I want to invite you
over for dinner at my house.
When you walk in,
there are chairs cramped everywhere,
smells delicious,
you hear people laughing,
you see friends hugging
and telling stories.
There are more than 20 of us here tonight.
Teachers, tech leaders, lawyers, moms.
It’s loud, and it’s chaotic.
But even if this is your first time,
it feels like home.
And then we'll sit down to work.
Because tonight is not a regular dinner.
Tonight is the culmination
of months of conversations
and learning in my living room.
At the end of this night,
30,000 dollars will go out
to a local grassroots nonprofit
that is doing amazing work
in our community.
And that money came
from everyone in the room.
And the decision of where
that money is going
included all of our voices.
This is a giving circle:
a group of people with shared values
that comes together to create change.
My giving circle,
the Peninsula Latina Giving Circle,
is what I know philanthropy to be.
It's joyful.
And transformative
and collaborative and intentional.
Most people don't see us
as philanthropists
or this process
when they think of philanthropy.
But I'm here to show you
the powerful possibility
that exists in all of us
to be philanthropists,
no matter your age or your wealth,
no matter where you live
or where you come from.
I am originally from Mexico City,
moved to the US 25 years ago,
and in 2007, when I started
my first giving circle,
I didn't even know the concept had a name.
This is not new.
Collective giving has been
going on for centuries.
Just in the past two decades,
thousands of giving circles
got started all over the world,
collectively giving more
than 1.3 billion dollars.
(Applause)
I have dedicated my life to this work.
And now I lead an organization
called Philanthropy Together
to democratize and diversify
the power of philanthropy
through the power of giving circles.
There are giving circles
with five members or 500,
each person giving
five dollars or 250,000,
iIncluding any generation,
identity or geography.
We give to nonprofits,
we give to individuals
or to new projects
just getting off the ground.
There are women's giving circles
and Black giving circles,
Jewish, Muslim and interfaith.
Giving circles that focus
on climate change
and civic engagement.
Cross-class and cross-race
giving circles.
Asian Pacific Islanders and Latinx LGBTQ.
Giving circles inside companies.
And social clubs and virtual.
There are giving circles in Malawi
and China and Germany.
So these groups keep
getting together year over year
because collective giving is powerful.
We can have a much bigger impact
together than we can alone.
So what is the secret?
I'm here to show you the four steps
to start a thriving giving circle.
The first step is to create belonging.
The concept of people
banding together to create change
is as old as humanity itself.
And collective giving has roots
in cultures all around the world.
But today we don't even talk
to our neighbors anymore.
But by belonging to something
that is bigger than ourselves
and the collective power
of our dreams and voices,
that is what creates that lasting
commitment to each other and to change.
Now [with] giving circles,
you start with a group.
Friends, neighbors, colleagues.
And you take the time
to deepen those relationships.
Those folks back in my living room,
we basically started as strangers.
But because we ate together
and laughed together and shared stories
and decided on our shared set of values,
we ended up creating a lasting community
that gets together year over year.
Giving circles make you feel at home.
The second step is to hold
space for discourse.
It can be completely,
completely overwhelming
to know how to make
an impact as an individual.
But in a giving circle,
you have the opportunity
to learn together.
Dozens of people engaging
in challenging conversations,
getting new perspectives
about the issues in their communities.
We work across differences
and ideologies and viewpoints.
But because everyone has an equal voice,
we always walk in with something to share
and walk away with something learned.
And back in my living room,
we’re tackling the hardest part:
to decide where are we giving together.
So we'll learn and then we'll vote,
and we'll discuss,
and we'll change our minds.
And then we'll change our minds again.
But beyond fail,
we always come to an agreement at the end
because we come with an open heart
and an open mind.
Now giving circle,
is not about me or you.
It's about us together.
And once we have shared and discussed,
the third step is to give with trust.
Because in a giving circle,
we give altogether
to a shared pot of funding
before even knowing
where that money is going to go.
We trust each other,
and that trust extends
to the groups that we're funding.
Tonight we're deciding
to give to a small nonprofit
with a tiny, tiny budget.
These numbers may shock you,
but in the US,
88 percent of funding
goes to just the top five
percent of nonprofits.
And groups led by Black and Latino leaders
get far less funding than similar groups
led by white leaders.
My giving circle,
we give as you would to a loved one,
looking them in the eyes.
And unlike most
of traditional philanthropy,
we give with no strings attached,
literally shifting the power
into the hands
of the leaders on the ground,
so they can decide
how to best use the money.
(Applause)
Because community knows
what community needs.
For any philanthropist,
it should never be about parachuting
into a community to “save” it.
Just acting alongside in partnership.
They don't need to be saved.
They need to be trusted.
(Applause)
And the last step
is just to act in abundance.
When people think of philanthropy,
they usually just think of big money.
And of course, you know,
money is a big part
of a giving circle, too.
Because of the multiplying effect,
my 100 dollars can turn
into 10,000 or 100,000.
You know, I even can make my kids look
outside of their phones for two minutes
and pay attention when I'm telling them
that I just gave 50,000 dollars.
But philanthropy literally
is love of humanity.
Giving with an abundance
of heart and of spirit.
We can all be radically generous
in so many ways,
beyond just money.
So after tonight,
we all are going to go
and volunteer and advocate
and open doors and share in social media.
We call this, in giving circles,
giving your five Ts:
time,
talent,
treasure,
testimony
and ties.
One of my favorite stories of abundance
is that of Martin Vargas Vega.
The son of migrant farm workers
whose dream was to become a coder.
Martin got trained by a small tech-skills
nonprofit in his community.
That nonprofit was supported
by the Latinos in Tech Giving Circle.
And for Martin, it was incredibly powerful
to see a group of people
that looked like him,
supporting and fueling the work
of the nonprofit
that was training him.
So after his training,
Martin landed this high-profile
internship in Silicon Valley.
And the very first thing he did
was give 50 percent,
half of his signing bonus,
to that nonprofit.
(Applause)
And wait.
And the other half
to join the Latinos in Tech Giving Circle,
because he is a philanthropist.
Martin is -- thank you.
Martin is actively using
his voice and his power
to bring more STEM programs
for kids that look like him.
That is abundance.
Life changing things happen
when we look at philanthropy
beyond the money,
because all the money in the world
is not going to save us.
But beloved communities will.
For a long time,
philanthropy has been just a select few
... that decide
on the impact on many
who should and shouldn't get funding,
what is and what is not
considered impactful.
Again, in the US,
communities of color
receive eight percent of philanthropy.
For women and girl's issues,
it's just 1.9 percent.
Not even one third of one percent
goes to the LGBTQ community.
We have to change that.
When we shift the power of philanthropy
into all of our voices,
we change who gives,
how we give,
and ultimately, what gets funded.
Giving by, for and with
the communities we represent
is the future of philanthropy.
And each and every one of us
belong in this movement.
(Applause)
Just think.
What if every town, every issue,
every community
had a giving circle with passionate
philanthropists like you?
So if you're looking
for impact and connection
and purpose
and joy,
join or start a giving circle,
no matter if you have
five dollars to give or 50 million.
No matter if you are a teacher
or a tech leader or a lawyer or a mom.
And if you do have millions
or billions to give,
join us in this movement.
Match a hundredfold or invest
alongside a local giving circle.
Thank you so much for coming
to my giving circle tonight.
In a world that feels heavy,
doing philanthropy together fills me
with so much joy and hope for the future.
Maybe when we started
you thought you were only
coming for dinner.
But actually, you just got
an invitation to change a world.
Let's meet at your house next time.
(Spanish) Gracias.
(Applause and cheers)